she used to be a bike mechanic
and she owns 10 bikes
which i am completely envy of i want to
get up to your level of bikiness
hopefully i will do that someday soon so
everyone both a double round of applause
both for just being a regular speaker
but also being a fill-in speaker and
helping us out
so much thank you very much katherine
[Music]
um so today i'm talking about why new
york are so jared mentioned this
but um i've been attending this
conference for
a while so since 2015 or 2016
um and i guess if i were to
speak to something that i care about
deeply but can also throw together a
talk on very quickly it would be
something like this
um but yeah first of all i just wanted
to i'm standing in for heather nolis who
is fantastic and you should follow her
on twitter
um and also hope that she gets better
soon but today i will be your substitute
teacher um
talking about um my experience with the
new york art community
and more generally um kind of the the
ways that it's helped me grow within my
career
um and yeah
so priorities first um so i actually
i got called in as let me try to
i got called in to uh share about this
i'm trying to bring my shirt interview i
ran a quick twitter poll
poll on what shirt i should wear um and
i have quite a collection
um so i'm starting this one won by
majority my crazy rich beijing shirt
that i got at a different conference but
it's pretty great
um and we'll hear more about this next
but
anyways a little bit about me i am
standing in today so i apologize that
this is a bit
scattered but um i'm a proud new yorker
and i um have been attending the new
york r conferences
for five years now um and i've also been
living in new york my whole life
um in addition to that i
i currently am the head of data science
at code academy before that i was at
jetblue
um in new york sports clubs um
and yeah i'm trying to make sure my
shirt stays on dude
okay um
so fun facts about me um i
adopted two rescue cats during
quarantine
and i've named them hue and stigma after
the normal distribution because that's
what you do when you're a statistician
um and uh steward cheered
i'm also a former bike mechanic and
right jared actually regularly
literally texts me for bike help um and
he'll just send me pictures of the bike
um and you should also quick plug join
this data bikers group um
where we do fun things
lately not so much but we certainly
still share photos of our rides
um and yeah i guess uh so the idea of
this talk kind of came around of like if
i were to give a quick last minute
talk right this is the thesis of it uh
um i kind of
came in i found this feat from last year
and i kind of came in to
the new york our community and stumbled
upon it as like a conference
attendee back in 2016
and the following year jared invited me
back to actually give a talk
and from there i found increasingly ways
to become more involved
culminating in getting food academy my
employer to
help sponsor this conference in this
community
um so yeah no solid agenda but this is
the rough pieces of what i'll be talking
about
um so i'll break this into parts and i
think part one
and um i know a lot of us feel this as
well
of you know attending my first data
science conference and more generally
kind of
you know trying to find community uh
within my career and feeling a lot of
loneliness and imposter
and syndrome lot of this oh i did want
to start this by saying
i do want to apologize to andrew gelman
because i made a
uh poke at him for not having slides
ever but he did have slides back in
2016.
and he also told us that trump might get
elected and we all ignored him
so um
but anyway 2016 what else is going on
besides
trump um i at the time was working at
jetblue a really large corporate company
um
and i'm sure many of you might still be
in this position
these bags are for my cats um might
still be in this position but when i
worked for jetblue i was the sole
kind of data person working on this
non-data science team
in this large large company and i was
just really lonely
so i stumbled upon new york r
um and was off to my first new york r
conference
um and i kind of reactivated my twitter
for this i wasn't heavy on twitter at
the time
um and i kind of have quick statistics
on my own end of my imposter student
dream i would say was
at an all-time high um i didn't have
any nerdy r friends to kind of talk to
you about stuff that i was thinking
about or interested in or
working on um back to
our community i think i was really
intrigued by it but i i wasn't really
involved in it
so after the conference again i had
attended the new york r conference for
the first time
and i was pretty excited i tweeted
um a lot throughout and was just kind of
um really happy about
all the stories i had about you know
going out and getting food with
vivian who designed a lot of that really
awesome artwork
and dan who gave that great talk um
earlier today and kind of meeting jared
and his dad
and you know hearing about our bike
ladies and gents and
and whatnot and um it was just really
warm and welcoming and i think to me
um you know my it felt like i was
starting to make our friends so it was
pending
um and jared kind of coming up to me and
saying like oh hey
like nice to meet you never having met
him before
um i'm kind of very quickly being like
you should come back and give a talk
um help me with my imposter syndrome a
bit which is still pretty bad but i
would say
um it started to make me feel like i had
a community
um so part two 2017 so
big gap 2016 2017 a lot happened in the
world too
um and i would say you know i kind of
thought that jared was
going to forget about the invite um but
sure enough a few months before the 2017
conference
oh uh he had reached out and
um you know i was like don't forget
about the invitation you're still
invited to speak
um and i was ready to share some
knowledge
so i do want to pause here and
i have a weird gimmicky thing but anyway
i couldn't decide on the shirts
so here was the next shirt that i have
which fun fact bigger than big r or
bigger than big data
i won at my first new york art
conference in 2016.
jared threw it to me in the audience um
my grandma once asked me what big data
is when she saw me wearing a shirt and i
was like don't worry grandma
nobody knows um anyway
2017 ready-ish to share some knowledge
so i was back and ready to give a talk
on airline data
um and my imposter syndrome again was
still pretty bad
um but i kind of came into the room and
was like whoa i actually recognized a
few people and jared came up to me
a few people i met last year and
throughout the monthly meetups came up
to me and
um yeah i kind of realized that the art
community is something special and draws
people including myself back and back
again
um and
yeah i i gave a talk and it was really
exciting and i think
um looking back on these pictures i look
so happy but in many ways i was so so
terrified
especially when i saw that my my photo
was up next to gilman's and i was just
like oh no jerry why would you do this
to me
um but it did a lot and i think
it just helped me grow a lot within my
career and also just
help with my confidence and i learned so
much
so conference talk 2017 the community
was so
kind and so welcoming um number of nerdy
our friends i made a few
um and giving back to our community i
just felt really grateful for the
knowledge sharing
and um i kind of noticed that throughout
the conference
in 2017 i was just like okay i'm a
speaker people are coming up to me
i feel compelled to make people who are
coming to this community for the first
time or new data scientists feel welcome
as well
so that was my way of giving back at the
time um
and i got i won another shirt so this is
this is so dumb um this is all right
so i got this shirt which is pretty cool
um hello all of the data things
um all right so in 2017
two big things happened i spoke at new
york r and
um i think in building that confidence
right um
and building you know just kind of a
network and
learning more about data science and
feeling really i keep coming back to
confidence but building that confidence
to kind of start looking at new
teams and careers i started a new job
actually with codecademy
um and i knew at the time that you know
i really really loved
the programming community and open
source and um
you know codecademy in many ways had
that same spirit
so all right what happened next
so giving back to the community um
i so between 2018 to
2019 um i just found myself feeling more
and more embedded
in the conference i i think i keep
saying meet up but
so the new york r um conference also
hosts a monthly meetup that
is um normally we convene in person and
there's pizza
and there's people and there's good
talking talks and whatnot
um so i kept going back to that
community and finding my own
ways to contribute um and i gave more
talks
so i gave a talk about forecasting
with time series data um at the meetup
which
um was a little bit scary um and that
the
meetup talk was a lot longer than my
comfort zone um
and yeah it was uh pretty exciting um
if you want to look for this online just
quick plug remember to vote
um i gave a talk on anomaly detection um
talked about oh right okay next next
shirt switch
so i really
love the tidy verse um and this is i
don't know if you can see
this one this one is i think therefore i
are
i think i mean i feel like it should be
i are therefore i think because you know
use our responsibly especially with
voting data
but anyway i digress um
and i also made more friends so between
2018 to 2019 um
our ladies we heard luda give a great
talk on this
um started in 2017 the second year i was
attending the conference as
speaker and it was great to kind of
watch that community grow and grow so if
you're looking at these photos
i really love this shift just
watching that network grow and just
feeling like there was a community
of people um who could motivate each
other and learn from each other and
celebrate each other that was really
amazing to see
and yeah um i'm like how many shirts
i've left
oh right and going back to this last
slide i i also made friends
um you know like i i talked about
learning from these people but in many
ways we were just
friends at the end of the day and we
went on bike rides together we ate pizza
together
we um taz jared and a few of us biked to
like new world mall to eat soup
dumplings together and it was just
it's yeah the community was so great um
and i brought a friend so um
you know the community was so awesome
that i was like you know what more
people
need to know about this so i tell people
about the new york art community all the
time
other data scientists might network um
and
also um in the with sebastian and
luda i am also part of a
nerdy data science couple so my partner
also i recruited him to come speak even
though he's not an r user
um and i got to use this xkcd joke about
statistically significant others
but yeah in many ways i just really just
wanted to help expand
the network of the our community and
also just introduce more people to it to
say like look how great this is
um sometimes data science and like
machine learning
jobs are so you're so back of office
that
it's hard to use working silos a lot of
the time and it just helps to learn and
kind of hear from other people
even if you're just kind of
commiserating about the same thing
um and by 2019 um
so 2019 and this year i got um academy
to become involved in sponsoring the new
york r conference
um so open source and events
like the new york bar conference happen
through partnerships and sponsorships
and
organizations who benefit from things
like our and programming communities and
their support
so last year we tabled in person
um and we had uh we're still in the
program again this year but
um last year we got a chance to meet all
of you in person
um here's uh ian is a member of the data
science team and
natalia over a lot of our great our
curriculum
um and yeah we found ways to get
involved
and give back and it felt like it was
fully coming full circle
um so in summary i guess um the ways
that
i've been able to contribute to the new
york r community
wait okay i think this is the last shirt
all right here are i have many of these
shirts
the color switches up every year so
here's part of my i
i went to the r studio conference by the
way and i ran into some folks from the
nba um who immediately saw my new york r
shirt and were like whoa so anyway and
that was in california a couple years
ago
um but ways to contribute to the
community show up
to your conferences and meet up um
just being there right you're
contributing you're kind of
providing momentum um if you can
if you want to join the conversation um
online on things like data science
twitter um i really love the data
science community because i think
this concept of like kind experts is
just really prevalent when you think
about people like hadley wickham right
like
um there's just this culture within our
community that's just very kind
and open to sharing um information and
knowledge
and you know making things accessible um
so i think in that spirit of that i
think
other ways that i try to contribute to
is nominating other
speakers especially if they're
first-time seekers just because it did
so much for my career and my confidence
and
impostor syndrome um and remembering to
give thanks to the people who kind of
put a lot of time and energy into the
community um
and you know becoming and being a kind
expert yourself
um and if you can find ways to sponsor
open source
initiatives whether it's finding ways to
partner with your employer
or finding ways to give a talk or
contributing to open source development
find a way to
help out with open source um
so kind of circling back to this tweet
right um where am i today i would say my
imposter syndrome
it never quite goes away but it does get
better um
so there's still some flare-ups from
time to time but it's much better these
days and i mean it
um and nerdy are friends i have too many
to count it's just
uh we're all virtual right now and i i
still feel a lot of comfort and i feel
like this is one of the highlights of
quarantine just kind of seeing a lot of
familiar faces even if it's virtual
um and giving bachelor our community i
mentioned it feels like
it's fully coming full circle from being
really nervous about going to my first r
conference and attending it to
speaking to becoming a sponsor um
and i say the word sponsoring that there
are many many ways you can
sponsor um and
final few minutes so um just quick
logistical things
um i wish we could
be there to meet you all in person last
year we were there with some cool demos
of like our online learning platform
um on text analysis so this is kind of
what we showed last year of like nlp
knows that
language wars are um not something
positive
um we're all friends here so our python
um but if you want to
learn about things like this feel free
to join us at codeacademy.com and we put
together a special discount code
new york r2020 that will get you 15
off um a pro membership
and um oh right last shirt okay this is
this is the last one
and we are hiring
so codecademy.com careers um
here is a non-comprehensive photo of the
data science team
at one of our recent stand-ups um
i i just think of like some of the many
many ways that i've benefited and kind
of
made use of the community i actually met
michael
at our monthly new york r at the monthly
new york art meetup last year
actually at ludo's talk i believe um and
she
works with with us now on the data
science team
um and camellia is giving her first new
york r
conference talk tomorrow um having just
moved from san francisco and being
induced into
or inducted into the new york r
community um
and that screenshot down there is just
an example of like the cool data we get
to work with just learning about
programming and um yeah kind of
languages and whatnot if you're a nerd
like us
come join us um and that's it
um i yeah this is a lot this is
really fun just reflecting on um
just meeting all of you and all of you
who i haven't met yet
and just kind of the feeling of being
together even when we're apart like i
said i think this is
one of my highlights of um quarantine
even if i had to put together a very
last minute talk but don't forget to
tune in tomorrow we have more talks
coming um
and yeah if you want to follow me on
twitter or github or
if you have questions i think i'm gonna
be around in some
q a room not sure oh i guess uh the
codecademy
booth i'll be there at some point today
and tomorrow
um and that's a wrap for me
i think i take it back to jared thank
you so much catherine for filling in for
us
and that was an excellent talk i'm glad
that i could have been a part of your
journey
it's really excellent seeing you come
from a uh nervous attendee to
someone here who could fill into the
last minute for us it's amazing seeing
that
so thank you so much on so many levels